[Music]
scampering continues on wants to be
undetected as long as possible here's
the best chance to set the crossfire to
fight that's all - what is prey as he
transfers back over guys having sick aim
in csgo is one thing
now having sick aim while controlling
the recoil of your fully automatic
weapon while moving the mouse laterally
well it's a completely different thing
that's right guys this week we're doing
the best of spray transfers no not those
sprays ease sprays it's gonna be all oh
my god what the [ __ ] guys I don't need
to tell you transferring your spray from
one target to another is no small feat I
mean you can't just hold down the left
mouse button and pray like I do
replay sends every following shot for
the same location
you need to know the spray pattern of
your weapon intimately well it solves
all over the place can they do anything
about this situation
position to try and catch them as they
rotate it does Oh snaps I like it your
perspective always inform talk to smoke
that's a bit of time down and rain to be
challenged here and he'll rise to the
occasion they're brilliant stuff from
rain free man spray doesn't have
steadily man this is the best chances of
the crossfire what is Frank three
players on 58th sighs renegade but I
think you can so far you holding the
angle very funny deep continuation spray
that is one of the most absurd things I
have seen in counter-strike please
somebody explain the science behind that
kind of nonsense
yeah mesma solar got himself a free shot
on - nothing early hominid whipped it
now the flashbacks I go out look at this
is free for nothing three fast kills it
gets trade but clearly the damage he
done is worth the trade the water
they've got a buy up with tech 9 some
armor with utility a little bit weaker
they're going to suspend it into the
site it actually messed up 1/2 smokes
and lays off Tetris and relics from
underneath sprays down for just Mouse
one
[Music]
we world in the pocket world yo so it
makes this round so much easier it would
be pants are it's as well with the flats
are a smart but these shuts them down
systematically picked them up are
focused on idealistic addicts the brain
houses know to not break the deadlock in
round thirty first council D goes
against NPS the devil's gonna hold the
spray transfers of poignant devil
blondes are triple death already he's
not yet played from secret Watsa and
that is incredible why don't you finish
that sentence Henry as Forrest gets
taken down fix it
pulls it back out from great secret is
busy turns around just me I deal shut
off he pulled on
where you put any one player in a spot
and sure enough there's the set up rain
with one look at home I gotta get the
transfer as well
unbelievable boasts the chemo hey say
that of a kid what's the first player oh
that is beautiful from Kyo be
well guys those were some sick spray
transfers but they were all plays where
the enemy was out in the opened in the
direct visual range of the player now
it's another thing entirely when you
have to rely on your instincts in the
middle of a transfer to tell you where
the next target might be
we're gonna call this next section the
best of multi-angle spray transfers he
could go big but it's multi get one a
bag needs to go ballistic he's gonna go
huge a bag gets a triple that's
ridiculous
with that empty not getting a lot of
information here it seemingly catching
them both out rubbish them with that
third heads your loss we'll get one and
he is now left alone 33 HP is it's
definitely doable here for lost but it's
gonna be incredibly tough what Merry
Christmas the animal lost are you
kidding me
what was that oh my god nice break from
him but it's gonna be all done in the
bow my god what the [ __ ]
yeah back to a free versus free
there's Cal exploding one there's Cal
exploding - and this kelex body exists
as well what kind of spray transfer that
was the Molotov is good but Eric when is
he gonna swing the ball service actually
has not spread that far and Eric they're
completely blind Eric he's gonna take
all four of them down huge flash coming
up about nine and one play actually
putting pressure on highway so they're
really trying to make sure if that
rotate can't happen safely for immortals
as they closed in but still gets
aggressive he finds two very well the
third that is as good as it gets for
steel holy cow coming up through the
bench leaving cold air and a Wallens for
there's the first looking for a second
he connects it again as well
but there's 11 seconds for the bomb to
go down the crimson on the site my just
weighs close to get right in front of
him through the play ridiculous let's go
track the front upon they were they
gonna take the round some Aeneas is
gonna be the man holding in Pitt but
even get smoked off here they even have
the incendiary the mod side gets
canceled it goes just a little bit too
far such a shame make it would have
taken a lot of damage instead NAFTA's
gonna take cajun who was alone make it
strong the double the triple there we go
the big plays coming in from the young
Danish star Phelps have plenty of time
and he's got 100 HP JD has extremely low
this could be all that a flash yet first
got to get aggressive here no he does a
peak with it whatsoever but there's a
good kill from Phelps first still hit it
for mo-more Cindy whips around for the
clutch frag off astronomers smoke is
down still dead underwater five-o no rat
especially let's drop my existence all
unzip safety right now he can hold off
on his bomb he beat hit the kill on to
these remaining T's that is gonna be
round over for phase and they don't have
the time six days he is flanked out of
his mind right now in IEM Sydney I have
never seen him hit a shot like that I
expect if he stays there they're gonna
put a Molotov on to that position quick
the adrenaline oh my god taking down zip
and debris what a miracle
phew KL and drop the bomb but thank you
the try see they can try to get right
back out the actual connector okay as
well but it's gonna be very fast right
now for a seal V they're gonna hear
footsteps up with a connector nothing
suck at language he does get the first
kill but alright and this is where you
turn things around and be like that was
pretty ducks for nothing well guys
that's all we got for you on best of
this week now if you do enjoy these
kinds of videos stay tuned because next
week we are dropping the top ten shotgun
kills for you you're up the [ __ ]
chain now until then go ahead and
transfer your mouth spray from the
subscribe button over to the
notification valve so you know whenever
we publish another csgo video and I'll
see you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]